how many of you get to the afternoon and
start to feel
tired lethargic fatigued you want to
take a nap but then you look at your
to-do list and you realize you still
have 77 things left to do the first and
easiest thing we can do
is
hydrate i know it doesn't sound like
rocket science and it isn't one of those
clever hacks but it can make a huge
difference alkaline water specifically
has a much bigger impact on your energy
levels as well so i try to stick to that
chances are when you're feeling tired
you're going to want to reach for
something with fats and carbs i know
when i get tired i want to reach for
some chocolate some donuts maybe a bagel
but that's not really what your body
needs
what you need is a high protein snack
and so you want to turn towards
something like fruits nuts seeds
anything that you actually may not want
at that moment you may not want to taste
it but i promise you you'll feel much
better for it now if you're a tea lover
you already know the benefits of a hot
cup of tea but if you're not i want to
let you know that certain teas have
herbs and adaptogens that help your body
get back up to balance so if you're
feeling stressed they'll de-stress you
if you're feeling anxiety they can lower
that down and on top of that the art of
taking a cup of tea
inhaling the scent
feeling it in your body
and then looking at the color
gives you that sense of pores that you
need in the day and re-energizes you
immediately
i recently did a test to check my
vitamins and i realized that i was
really deficient in vitamin d the doctor
explained to me that because of the
color of my skin no matter how much time
i spend in the sun i need to be taking
vitamin d now she was actually shocked
that i could even get out of bed that's
how much vitamin d is connected to our
energy levels so if you're starting to
feel fatigued a bit earlier than usual
get a vitamin d check and start taking
some vitamin d need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best jay shetty and my take on
his top 10 rules for success enjoy
rule number two learn from the past
learn from the past but don't live there
this is actually a picture of don
schuler famous nfl coach if you like nfl
one of the most well respected nfl
coaches and he had this great theory
well not theory practice
he gave his all his players
24 hours only to celebrate a success
or cry over a loss he said you've got 24
hours to feel your emotions 24 hours to
success be successful champion it have a
celebration whatever you want to do
you've only got 24 hours make the most
of that 24 hours and if you're gonna cry
i'm giving you 24 hours after that we
forget about it and the reason why i
love this statement is this statement
learned from the past but don't live
there is usually used as saying our past
is negative
but i want to apply it to the positive
as well often we sit back
and with nostalgia reflect on our best
memories right and this nostalgic thing
makes us still live in the past and it
doesn't necessarily have build for the
future one of my favorite examples of it
is when steve jobs went back to apple
he went in there and the first thing he
did is that he crushed the museum that
they built of all the history apple had
because he said he didn't want to be
working for a company that was built on
just all of this past recognition and
success he wanted to be building a
company of the future he got rid of this
big museum they had in the entrance of
apple when he went back after
losing his job the first time
and so this is what i'm talking about
let's not live in the past right
let's learn from the past but not live
there and they did some great studies
with the armies they did with the us
army and they did this with the israel
defense forces and i'm sure you do this
at work so they did after action reviews
but i'd love for you to do this in your
own life so they found that when they
had two groups of soldiers one group of
soldiers reflected on only the failures
of all of their actions and the other
group reflected on the failures and
their successes
they found after doing this for a
certain amount of time they found that
the soldiers that focused on both the
failures and successes not only
performed better in future tasks they
were betterly mentally situated to
actually inspire and empower their
colleagues as well
so when you're reflecting don't just
learn from the past by learning from the
failures learn from the successes as
well build them into that because we
start developing a story and a pattern
for life rule number three have a
schedule i spent years of my life
working really hard from monday to
friday
only to have to wake up on a saturday to
do all my cleaning not only did that
take up the whole day it made less time
for social interaction for connecting
with friends and family and even time to
work on my passions and what ended up
happening is that by the time it was
monday again the house felt unclean and
i felt like i'd made no progress
initially we all believe that doing it
in one day seems like the best method
it's out of sight out of mind you don't
have to think about it for the whole
week and in one day you get it sorted
the challenge with that is that in your
mind it also feels like a bigger
mountain to climb scheduling it out
during the week makes all the difference
tackling small tasks putting things back
immediately after using them washing a
plate immediately after eating something
makes it so much simpler one of the best
ways to do this is to create days
dedicated to specific things this makes
it feel like a challenge or an
experiment so for example a wipe down
wednesday knowing that all you have to
do is wipe down your surfaces may take
no more than five to ten minutes i also
really love floor fridays now the floor
can sometimes take a bit longer but
still scheduling out around 30 minutes
to do that could make all the difference
and if you live with more than one
person you can divide these days and
these areas between you so that you can
make it simpler and easier to handle and
tackle there's quite a few benefits to
this when we do the same thing at the
same time on the same day every single
week it becomes so much easier for the
mind to tackle that task when we divide
and dissect our tasks up in this way we
avoid burnout we avoid feeling like we
have this big huge mountain to climb and
solve and we start tackling elements
every single day rule number four be
present when you're feeling anxious
what's happening is that your mind is
either rushing to the past
or it's predicting and projecting the
future so you're either anxious about
something that you experienced before or
you're feeling really nervous and
anxious about something that might or
could happen in the future the best way
to come back into the present moment is
the five four three two one method
you want to start off
by looking around wherever you are and
noticing the five things you can see it
could be the windows
the walls the ceilings you then want to
focus on the four things you can touch
it could be something you're wearing and
you really want to feel the texture it
could be what you're sitting on
just noticing it and really grounding
yourself and holding on to that then
it's about three things you can hear it
could be nothing
it could be white noise
then the two things you can smell inhale
could be a scent you're wearing it could
be a flower and then finally the one
thing you can taste
when you practice this it brings you
back into the present moment
and helps you not focus on the anxiety
of the nervousness but on taking action
from exactly where you are
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five don't seek
validation he was a ceo
of a very large car manufacturer and he
was known to be extremely successful
very productive very effective
but the one thing he was failing at is
that his employees really didn't like
working for him because he worked late
how many of you feel that way
oh perfect that's good so no one here
finishes late or everyone's managers are
in the room whichever whichever way you
want to take it it's up to you right
it's up to you
i don't know
so
that was one of his challenges that his
his employees hated work for him because
they all left late because of him he
used to work till 10 p.m every evening
so they would leave just after him true
story right they used to leave just
after him so one of his assistants she
came and said this to him she said you
know morale's a bit down
everyone's struggling at work you know
we're losing a few people a few people
are quitting their work you know people
they're not well they don't feel like
their health is being taken care of
they're not spending enough time with
their families you really need to
consider this
he said okay leave it with me we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
from the next week on a monday
this gentleman who left at 10 pm every
night got up out of his desk at 6pm he
packed his bag switched off his computer
left the office jumped into his car and
all the employees at this time are like
peeking out the window you know just
like making sure like figuring out where
is this guy going he pulls into his
beautiful car pulls out and drives away
from the building
it's the first time it ever happened at
6 00 pm
they all decided to wait till 7pm before
they left
they waited and they left
on tuesday the same thing happened they
looked out the window again he left at 6
p.m again this time they went till 6 45
and they left
they did the same thing and this
happened for three months where he left
at 6 00 pm every day
three months later his assistant who
made him aware of this challenge she
came back to him and she said to him i'm
really confused about something she said
you've been leaving four hours earlier
every single day but you're not behind
on your calls you're not behind on your
emails and you're still performing at
the same level if not better than when
you were leaving on time and she said
how are you managing to do this are you
working at home
how are you managing this he said let me
tell you something interesting
he said every day i get into my car at 6
00 p.m i drive out he said i take a
drive for an hour he said i take that
drive i listen to music i re-energize he
said i sometimes go for a bit of a walk
at the park as well he said i come back
fresher at 7 00 p.m and i work for three
more hours
and he said if it helps them knowing
that i've left at 6 pm so that they can
have a better life and have the values
that they want and value what they want
to give their time to
that doesn't mean i've got to give up
what i value my time to he said i love
my work i love being here till 10 p.m
i'm extremely ambitious i love being
here but they should also love being
where they are
and that to me is a incredible example
of how someone actually lives foregoing
the perception of others even though he
changed his own life to help other
people they'll never perceive him that
way they just think he's changed his
mind and he goes home early they don't
realize the struggle that he's putting
in and that's what i've realized whether
you're putting in struggle or sacrifice
never look for the validation or
approval of others
to validate that sacrifice or that
struggle
because they don't need to understand
anyway it's always been your inner
journey it's always been part of your
inner growth and i remember when i made
a decision to become a monk after
business school all my friends are like
what the hell are you doing right we
just finished and everyone's going off
to work at goldman sachs and different
banks and consulting firms etc i think a
few people came to google as well and
they all said to me they said they said
what do you mean you're becoming a monk
like what does that mean like who
graduates and thinks about that and i
remember having to detach and when i
reflect and i'd love for you to do this
reflect on some of the best decisions
you've made on your life
ask yourself what decision did you make
what did people say about it and what
was going on in your mind
i've learned through doing that exercise
it's a much longer exercise it can take
days and we do it in our coaching
exercises i've learned that the best
decisions in my life have been the
biggest risks everyone's disagreed with
me but i've been hell-bent on making it
happen and so now when i see an
opportunity like that i do it because
i've realized that that's the pattern of
the philosophy of my life when i make
decisions that are big risks no one
agrees with me
and it doesn't fit with what society is
saying those work out to be my best
decisions in life and i'm not saying
that that's your pattern i'm saying that
you have a pattern and a rhythm as well
and it's part of your journey to find it
rule number six prepare for the next day
after i've completed my work day when i
finished all of my tasks the last thing
i do
is check my schedule for the next day
now i'm one of those people that follows
their schedule to a tea i believe it
makes life simple when i get my schedule
out and look at the next day i can think
about how i'm going to feel i've got too
much or too little on that do i want to
add or edit something it gives me
perspective and allows me to get a
glance on the next day so i can
rearrange or reorganize based on the
energy i feel today sometimes we feel so
tired and exhausted but without making
that change and edit we take that
exhaustion in the next day the other
reason why i like looking ahead is that
it gives me an opportunity to mentally
prepare i may have a podcast the next
day and there's a guest that i'm really
excited about and i may have to calm my
nerves or sometimes it's an event or a
meeting that i'm looking forward to and
i just want to go over the bullet points
before i go to bed it gives me an
opportunity to rehearse the day in
advance and often i'll even sit and do a
short visualization just to imagine how
tomorrow will look rule number seven
connect to the right story terry
pratchett a famous author whether you've
already stuff or not a famous author he
said
that people feel
that stories are defined by people but
actually it's the other way around
people are defined by stories when
you're listening to me today i've shared
so many stories with you because we
define ourselves by the stories we tell
ourselves on a daily basis the story you
wake up to will be the story that will
be the story of your day
right if you wake up and you tell
yourself a positive story you'll have a
positive day you wake up tell yourself a
negative story you'll have a negative
day positive and negative thoughts are
like seeds that either grow weeds or
plants
right
they grow inside of us throughout the
day anytime you plant something it's
like planting a seed and the more you
water it the more you think about it
grows and of course it's negative it's
like a weed and it starts to grow and
grow and grow and of course won't bear
fruits
so really think about that tell yourself
the right stories connect with the right
stories because ultimately the universe
is made up of stories not atoms and
numbers right we all love stories we
read stories your life is a living story
that you're writing every day and i
genuinely mean that rule number eight
use scents and music a lot of the time
we're trying to control anxiety up here
and what i find is hard about that is
that if you feel like you've got brain
fog or you're feeling cloudy it becomes
really difficult to find clarity i find
using external things can be huge for me
i love diffusers and candles because a
diffuser is
infusing the whole environment with a
beautiful scent and it truly changes
your mind if you walk into a space just
think of a spa as soon as you walk in
you feel different because of the scent
it could just be a normal room but the
center of lavender sandalwood any of
these essential oils can truly calm your
body right down
some people feel that silence creates
anxiety and some people feel that sound
creates anxiety
sometimes i like complete silence it
helps me relax and really hear my
thoughts and the thoughts that i want to
focus on and sometimes i need to turn on
some meditation music some ambient music
just to have that impact on me
please use music in your environments in
different rooms in your home to help you
achieve different emotions and feelings
that you want to feel at that time rule
number nine
clean when i first joined the ashram i
was asked to do a lot of cleaning and in
the beginning i found it tedious and a
waste of time what if i could be serving
humanity what if i could be reading a
book what if i could be studying and
making notes and i had all these excuses
in my mind but of course i'd chosen to
be a monk and therefore i was encouraged
to clean
and i started to find that cleaning did
so much for my mind and recently i
looked at some studies that actually
backed that up there are so many
benefits of cleaning in a physical space
that will also clear out your mind a
recent study from ucla by saxby and
repety found that cleaning gives you a
better sense of control over your
environment and engages your mind in a
repetitive activity that can have a
calming effect and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is have fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the fun of it
okay so we did it here it goes uh
really proud of what we did it was fun
it was fun doing it
i read this amazing quote by richard
branson that says we don't stop playing
because we get old but we get old
because we stop playing and i realized
in the pandemic just how much i loved to
play whether it was a game of katan
whether it was a game of tennis i just
knew that i had to be more active
mentally and physically
with the value of play now often play
scene is something that should be
reserved for the weekends it's seen as
something that you put off as a treat
well why can't we break it down and
treat ourselves in the middle of a day
maybe it's playing a game of cards maybe
it's playing a video game if you just
want to take that break to beat your
next record or maybe it's just doodling
or messing around or calling up a friend
and having a playful conversation
the point is that play can be used as a
reward as a treat throughout the day you
don't have to put it off now for those
people that can be quite addictive
personalities like me and find that if
you turned on a video game at 2 pm you
may still be paying it at 10 p.m set a
timer before you start allow yourself to
get that one game of fifa or mba 2k in
like i would and then get back to work
doing something fun and exciting can
increase blood pressure dopamine and
your heart rate giving you the energy
boost you need talk about detachment i'm
just like that that i think is is is one
of the hardest things that we face today
it is 100 and and one of the ways we
were trained and i'm not i'm not
recommending this to anyone watching i'm
just sharing how
how much we are obsessed and addicted to
the body we were trained to not look in
the mirror
oh wow so we didn't i didn't look in a
mirror for like three years
wow right like no way effectively yeah
as you know i looked in the mirror again
when i had to
but you don't look in the mirror to look
at your appearance
i'm not saying that i don't recommend
that before you go to work tomorrow or
anything like that but just listen to
the principle you're going to get a uh
yeah
i can't even yeah
so the reason is and that's the reason
why monks have shaved heads too because
you focus less on your physical
appearance you spend less time on your
physical appearance what that allows you
to do is it literally dissolves your
understanding of your physical presence
which means all you have to deal with is
the inside
just think about how much attention it
takes to keep ourselves well groomed to
take care of ourselves to
our ego and attachment to how good we
look and i have it too right we all have
it like i'm not saying i'm detached from
that but what i'm saying is that we were
trained in the belief that if you're
able to switch off and close your eyes
why don't we close our eyes when we
meditate right it's because it detaches
us from the physical presence of where
we are so that we can go inside i feel
like we give we give our toxic
relationships and negativity so much
energy
we're like cons like for example in your
comment section on instagram for anyone
who's on social media for everyone who's
on social media
you could pinpoint the one negative
comment out of a hundred positive
comments and we all do it we amplified
the negative and you see all the time
and we do the same in our lives where we
sit here talking about all the toxicity
and so for me it's like i can either
spend all my energy trying to convince
that one person to love me
or
i can reply to the people that love me
already and they'll love me more
because they already engage with me and
they're going to feel so happy that i
responded to them and i think this is a
great simple tip for everyone who's
listening it's just when you respond to
positivity in your life it just
increases when you respond to the
negativity in your life it just
increases and so trying to get someone
to like you and defend yourself and
control how they feel about you it
wastes and drains so much energy and you
can use all that energy for the people
that love you when we were put out on
the streets with nothing
nothing but had to fend for ourselves
and you recognize how you can actually
live with very little
and how you need very little to get by
whether it was fasting like not being
able to eat for several days or drink
for several days you recognize how
grateful you are for what you do have
and so these mini experiments that are
very extreme that i'm not saying anyone
has to do i'm not recommending anyone at
home to do them all i'm trying to say
is that the body is like a vehicle we
have to take care of it just because you
have a nice car you've got to take care
of that nice car but if you don't feed
the driver that car's not going anywhere
and so many of us have become more
addicted to the vehicle than we have to
the driver inside and so the way of
tapping into that driver inside is spend
time with people who know their driver
really well and that's why monks were
such a big part of my growth because you
meet people who have no agenda want
nothing from you want nothing of the
world and they're not trying to get
somewhere like there's no there's no
win-win it's only win for you
there's no win in it for them
and and being around the energy of
realized people
who have that realization who've been
with their consciousness for 10 20 30 40
years that's a huge part of it we're
being built for a job or we've been
built to be in a box right we're being
built so that we fit into society and i
find it funny right it's like when
you're a kid you're told to fit in like
you probably remember this stay in line
like fit in yeah everyone has to wear a
uniform everyone dresses the same
everyone has to do this and then when
you grow older what are we all trying to
do we're all trying to stand out it's
weird it's like your whole life you're
trying to fit in and then as soon as you
grow older it's like oh you need a
personal brand now you need to stand out
like do you know your own voice you need
to stand out
how do you deal with it when the doubt
is coming from the people that you
really love and you know they care about
you
yeah it was hard i didn't go to my
graduate i graduated but never went to
my graduation ceremony so my mom doesn't
have a picture of me
holding my degree and that was a big
thing for her because i moved to india i
just went so i never went to that and
that was a big thing for her and
actually my parents i'm very grateful my
mom and dad are actually fairly liberal
and supportive of anything i've decided
to do it's my extended family that's had
more opinions and been more involved and
kind of stirring stuff up with my
parents if that makes sense so the way i
dealt with it was always asking myself
these questions around you know
is someone invested in my future
is someone gonna be there for me when
i'm struggling and is someone paying my
bills like those are my three checking
system of who matters in life like your
soul your mind and your paycheck
and i think the biggest thing i asked
myself was just
am i going to look back on if i don't do
this am i going to look back going back
to the alexander the great story
am i going to look back on my deathbed
and say
my mom and dad held me back
because i may say i'm going to do it for
them i'm not going to do this decision
because i respect them and love them but
am i going to hate them in the end or be
bitter towards them or feel a negative
feeling towards them because i feel they
held me back
and if that's the truth i never want to
feel that about my parents they're
incredible
so i need to go and take the
responsibility to make this shift
and i think the truth is that
when we think people are holding us back
it's just us not taking responsibility
for us to push forward like that's all
it is because the truth is if you really
really really really really want
something right like if someone told you
right now you had to get on a plane and
there's a million dollars in new york no
one would say oh my parents can't afford
to play like no one would say that you
would you would do it if you really
wanted it you'd get on a plane right now
and you go pick that million dollars up
so it's our own insecurity that we
reflect onto the people around us and i
think it's really important i get it
there are people who are toxic around us
i get it i had that too there were
people who were just like
literally people said to me like you
realize you're gonna fail at being a
monk you realize when you come back no
one's gonna hire you you realize when
you come back no one's gonna want to be
with you you really you know there are
so many things like people like you know
you're going to be socially dead like no
one's going to care where you are there
was so much of that
but it didn't get amplified because i
was strong in my conviction so the way i
dealt with it was just keep
strengthening your conviction rather
than trying to weaken the argument
because the
the opinions of others will get weakened
when you strengthen your own right
that's how it works you don't weaken
someone else's to strengthen your own
we're so used to in our life
having instant judgment defining a
moment and giving it a label good or bad
in the moment and i thought how do i
present a concept to the world
where we can laugh at ourselves and
realize that sometimes our instant
judgment or our instant labeling
processor isn't always correct yes how
do we how do we get that so this script
or narrative that i shared in this video
is on a gentleman who goes to buy these
cookies because he feels like having a
few cookies because his flight's delayed
and he sits down to eat these cookies
and the gentleman opposite him where
you're sitting right now starts to take
cookies out as well
and he's saying how's this guy and the
guy looks a little rugged he looks a
little scruffy he doesn't look put
together so naturally all of our biases
our unconscious biases start coming up
and stemming up and we start thinking oh
he looks a little shady or maybe he
doesn't have money that's why he's
taking my cookies and we have this
impression of i me and mine these are my
cookies how can he take them
only to realize when he leaves that your
cookie box was in your bag
and that gentleman was sharing his
cookies with you
and then this person has this epiphany
or this moment of realizing how quick he
was to judge but how wrong he was and i
think all of us in different ways have
different moments in our life where
whether we misjudged a person the first
time we met them or we misjudged someone
because of the first thing they said to
us or we had a friend that now is our
best friend but our first impression was
oh they're a loser and all of a sudden
now we think they're amazing emotional
intelligence to me
is being able
to be aware of yourself self-awareness
being able to know yourself that's the
highest form of eq right like being able
to say i know when i'm at my best i know
when i struggle and i know when this is
a limiting belief or not and then being
able to process all of that so we're not
helping people
we i love saying this because it it
simplifies it but we teach people what
to think not how to think right we tell
them two plus two is four but we don't
tell them how to think about a problem
and that's why when you're faced with a
new problem
and you don't have a formula for it you
don't have an equation for it you're
like oh i'm stuck right and life's like
that like when in life have you used a
formula to solve a real situation like
even business yeah like when has a
formula helped you yeah but we're taught
that formulas solve equations but we all
know that there's no formula to business
success happiness meaning et cetera et
cetera et cetera yeah i literally skip
over negative comments genuinely since
day one and i remember reading them this
time so i'll add this there have been
times when i've looked at negative
comments
and they're like huh that's quite funny
like you know it's
funny they're true but overall i try to
respond to everyone who said something
positive and i rarely put any energy in
to put anyone who put anything negative
because i don't want to change their
mind they're entitled to their belief
they're okay to feel that way and if i
feel like it's good feedback i'll take
it on board but if i feel like it's just
someone being a keyboard warrior and you
know doesn't like me and saying what
they want then i'm not going to take
that seriously yeah it's pretty easy to
tell the difference between the two 100
if there's some authenticity and truth
behind it it's a much different comment
than just unabashed hate yeah absolutely
and i've had everything from he has a
wind machine in his videos to make sure
his hair slides right like i've had that
that angle and you don't i don't i just
went out on a really windy day this is
like exclusive on the podcast this is an
excuse for the podcast i do not have a
wind machine
but i've had everything from that and i
laughed at that i thought that was a
hilarious comment through to the other
side of just like you know i don't agree
with you and i don't agree with the
point you're making this is my point and
i'm like yeah you know what i had three
minutes to explain that and i missed
that point like you're right you know i
agree with you if i had a podcast like
this i could have explained myself
so you know i but i do think that we do
drag our own selves down we
put all the energy into the negativity
and amplify it i love the story i'll
tell you because i love this too and it
shows so
and he'll like this story so marcus
aurelius if you haven't read meditations
by marcus aurelius highly recommend it
marcus aurelius emperor meditations is
his personal journal
and one of the stories that i love about
him that that comes up in a few
hollywood movies too is that once when
he was walking through the roman town
square
he used to have his advisor follow him
around and whenever people would glorify
him and praise him
the person's job was to come into his
ear and whisper you're just a man you're
just a man just to remind him
just to remind him in that moment where
you just you know in that moment where
you just feel like your ego is going
through the roof because everyone's
saying you're amazing you changed my
life etc a to remember you just a man
and i would add to that remember the
people who made you that right remember
the people who gave you that and so
that's how i've learned to balance ego
is by any time i'm glorified or praised
or appreciated or recognized i'm passing
that off to my teachers guides mentors
the universe and
accepting it on their behalf
so if i receive an award i actually
don't think it's mine i'm accepting it
on behalf
of everyone who made me the way i am
it's beautiful whether it was positive
or negative too one of my favorite
thoughts from martin luther king is if
you want a new idea read an old book
what old books
many different ones the bhagavad-gita is
probably one of my favorite books it's
it's been such a huge part of my
personal journey and personal life uh
many other religious texts as well so
the bible has been a big part of my
study i spent a lot of time with the
bible and and then it can just be
thoughts and ideas even if the last two
thousand years so stoicism a huge fan of
marcus aurelius meditations that's been
a huge book for me that i've studied and
sometimes old can just mean 50 years or
100 years ago too but those are some of
the bigger ideas that i think have had
more prominent effects in my life so
vedic and stoic knowledge has probably
been the most influential after a long
time the other day my friends and i went
bowling and i started to think to myself
that life
is a lot like home
bowling is a team sport just like life
in bowling sometimes the best players
struggle and others that were less
likely to do well surprise you and make
all the difference
this is one of my favorite lessons
focusing on someone else's score
doesn't make yours any better it's easy
to get distracted by how well someone
else is playing you see their score go
up they bowl a strike or a spare you're
calculating in your mind what you think
that could be
but all that does is it distracts you
from your game similarly in life
focusing on someone else's instagram
grid doesn't make yours any better
focusing on what someone else is doing
for work or what they're driving doesn't
make yours any better focus on yourself
focus on your own role your strengths
that will make all the difference i'm
able to not judge myself because i don't
judge others a lot of people who are
like a lot of right so tell me i don't
know i'm so powerful no i love that
that's such a great point how do you
that's such a great point no you're spot
on because the reason why
we have
we judge others is because we judge
ourselves right the opposite of what
you're saying and so for me it's the
same thing the reason why i don't expect
is because i see everything as my
responsibility yep i see everything as
my work yes and i see everything else as
a bonus like it's just amazing that
anyone even cares about me or has time
for me or makes an effort to do
something or connect with someone
whatever it is and that's just a
beautiful bonus of life but i've got to
be in charge of it and i think that just
came from many years of having
expectations i think that came from
times when i did expect and i didn't get
and i realized i don't want to feel this
way anymore i always talk about there's
two types of create well there's three
types of creators but we usually end up
one of the two so there's the sellout
creator a sellout creator only goes with
what the audience wants so you literally
forget about anything you care about or
believe in you just go for what you
think is going to get likes and then the
opposite is the selfish creator who only
creates for themselves they're like i
think this is amazing like i'm the
funniest person in the world or i'm the
deepest person or whatever it is and you
create something and like no one wants
to watch it because you literally made
it for you and your mom like you know
it's kind of like sits there and so i
always aim for being in the middle i
recognize that i want to stand for what
i believe in but i also want it to
connect and resonate and have a positive
impact on other people's lives so that's
my starting point that every piece of
content should be true to me but it
should resonate with people it should
make a difference i set a goal very
early on that my videos were only 75
complete and i say this everywhere
actually i have never said it often i've
never said it on a podcast but i've said
it often on stage and events my videos
are only 75 complete which means i mess
words up often so you'll see that
sometimes my sentence wasn't perfect i
mispronounced a word i developed a lisp
on a word because it was in flow and i
said it and it wasn't right but it felt
right
and
other things where i finished a shoot
and we forgot a shot that was huge for
the video but i'm like it's all right 75
so my goal with every video is 75
and i've had to do that because i've
realized that if i wait for 75 to 99
i'll be waiting for a year and a half or
three years two videos
i have two videos right and we've
released three videos a week right now
and so for me the goal was always 75 and
i love that yeah and i personally think
that's a great aim because 75 is
realistic it's quality so you're not
settling for less but 75 to 99 is such a
long journey i really started to get
fascinated in my teens my father became
very spiritual when i was 10 years old
and i actually saw that was very weird
because why did he do that i think he
went through now when i look back on
hindsight he went through his sort of
like mid-life crisis journey search at
the age of 40 where he was married had
two kids had a decent job in the city
but didn't feel satisfied and didn't
feel fulfilled and so he went off and i
was 10 years old he went on his search
so he went from everything from
reiki and healing to church of
scientology through to all the religious
truths and was just searching for
answers
and when he did that that was actually
quite alien and weird for me and my
family because we thought i just got mad
because i guess it was my first
experience of what a midlife crisis
or midlife journey looks like so that
actually deterred me from spirituality
because
it was almost like he was letting the
family down and it was tough for my mom
and all the rest of it so that was that
was kind of how my teens were spent but
then i got fascinated by it because i
remember it was one christmas and we
used to celebrate christmas every year
we used to wrap presents have a
christmas tree and one year i just felt
like a hypocrite i was just like i don't
know anything about jesus and i don't
know much about christianity i was about
15 years old and i was like but we
celebrate christmas like why do we
celebrate christmas so then i started i
remember i went to church that year uh
on christmas day and christmas eve just
because i felt like a hypocrite and i
felt that i should at least understand
or try and take an interest in what i
was doing we've all heard the story and
i'm just sharing it again to give
context we've all had the story of the
two wolves or the two dogs however you
want to phrase them if you haven't i'll
i'll tell it now it's it's a story of
how inside of us there are two dogs two
wolves and they're fighting for
supremacy so inside you
one is the initiator and one is the
responder
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator so your
initiating wolf is strong
powerful
bulky aggressive because it's been fed
well your whole life
and your responsive dog your responsive
wolf has not been fed has not been
listened to
and so it's weak
and feeble and meek and and humble and
doesn't even stand to fight so when they
too come to fight inside of you this
this wolf's just gonna eat that wolf
right up and that's what's happening
right now so for all of us whatever two
wolves you're seeing whether it's your
mind and your intelligence whether it's
your
intuition versus what your parents say
whether it's
expectations of society versus your
expectations of yourself like whatever
two wolves you have inside of you the
one that wins is the one you feed and
the ones you have been feeding
now if you're at a point where you are
and where i am and where all of us are
in different scenarios of our life we're
trying to shift and start feeding the
other one
it's hard because the other one's just
been fed more it's stronger it's able to
push you it's able to dictate you
and this is where detachment's so key
that detachment doesn't mean that you
owe nothing detachment means that
nothing owns you
and most of us have become owned
by our darker wolves most of us have
become owned by the self that we don't
want so so that conditioning has been
drawn up the only way to break it is to
disrupt the pattern to really break that
it has to be and this is why i talk to
people about immersive experiences like
you meditating for 10 minutes a day on a
headspace that's wonderful and i
recommend it but that's not going to
shift this in a drastic way
you are going to have to go and spend a
week out in joshua tree with the shaman
you are going to have to take a break
islam in jerusalem right we were both in
love with jerusalem like instead of
going on a holiday this year you are
going to have to go on a three-day
intensive transformative retreat and the
reason why i'm saying all these
different things is they all have
different budgets they're all available
in different countries you don't have to
go to india and live with monks
but you have to do something and it has
to be immersive because when you get
immersed in something then you're giving
something the power to break your
pattern right and i think the challenge
is we're trying to solve it by a little
thing every day which is a good start to
get us going but if you're really
serious about a massive shift in your
life wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah you need to go
water that you need to go feed it you
need and you need to go give it energy
and that's what i think
we find that
and that's why i think people struggle
they still want to go on their beach
holiday
they they're like no i can't give that
up i need that
or this weekend i still need to go and
do up my house and it's like well no
like just imagine what would happen if
this weekend you just went on a
three-day retreat that changed your life
like imagine if you just gave that
energy in terms of finding your purpose
that seems like it's the first step
getting comfortable with yourself
understanding that how do we take that
next step towards finding that purpose
yeah so for me i i define it as
your passion is for you your purpose is
for others so your purpose is when you
use your passion to serve others that's
the the link so for me the focus
actually first becomes what's your
passion like what are you passionate
about what do you enjoy doing and then
the mis the parts that that's usually
miss everyone here is follow your
passion find your passion it's like a
cliche it's everywhere the difference is
get really good at it
like get so good at it and everyone
always misses that point you can be as
passionate as you want about tennis
but if you're not really good at tennis
no one's gonna care and no one's gonna
take no and i think that's off to missed
that not only do you need to find what
you're passionate about you need to turn
it into an expertise
which is undeniable and that requires
the hard work that requires the work
ethic that requires the early mornings
that requires the training in whatever
field you want to be and then
and that's going to make you successful
so when you figure out your passion and
you get really good at it you're going
to become successful but you're only
going to be happy when you use that
success to help other people and then
you've got to figure out that link to
purpose so you're going to find your
purpose so when you realize hey i'm
really good at this i love it i get a
lot of happiness from doing it when you
start using that to make a difference in
other people's lives in any way it
automatically switches into a purpose so
you don't need to find your purpose it's
just an automatic evolution
of finding your passion and being really
good at it and that's where we're
messing up that we haven't found
something we love
and we haven't found something that we
love that we've got really good at so
what we usually do with our lives is we
do things that we're not good at and
don't love
right or we do things that we're good at
but don't love
and we need to switch into the spaces of
things that we love but are not good at
and get really good at them and start
finding out things that you are good at
and you do love there's different ways
to play the game
some people spin the ball some people go
for a straight direct role some people
use two or three things the list
continues and the truth is it's exactly
the same in our lives you will see some
people succeeding in a certain way and
others doing it completely differently
the goal is to find your way your method
your approach the direction that works
for you without trying to copy or mimic
or imitate someone else
and we've all experienced this
sometimes your ball
ends up in the gutter i'm sure you've
had that before sometimes your throw was
completely out of control and your ball
went directly into the gutter
or maybe sometimes you actually felt
well prepared and confident but the ball
still ended up in the gutter in life
just like that ball
sometimes we feel we're in the gutter
but there's something to learn from that
and just like the ball comes back
when we learn through our experience
we get another opportunity to improve
another opportunity to try another
opportunity to succeed as oscar wilde
said
all of us are in the gutter but some of
us are looking up at the stars sometimes
you hit a spare
you threw your best shot you got the
angle perfectly right you prepared with
everything you had
and that one pin
is still
up there
sometimes despite our best efforts in
life
we don't get what we want
not everything aligns everything doesn't
go to plan
life is a lot like bowling keep your
eyes on the ball your concentration in
the game
and your mind out of the gutter
and in the end we realize we have to be
just like that bowling pin
no matter how hard we're hit by life no
matter how hard we're hit by others
we have to keep
stepping back up that has happened so
many times when a video you think's
gonna hit
and it doesn't and then there's a video
you're like that's never gonna hit and
it does
and
that's where i've reconciled myself down
is recognizing that i don't always know
what's going to work
and that's a beautiful thing
and that i've been and i and i've been
feeling this often that
i've got to where i want in life just
not in the way i imagined it
and that's the beauty of
giving up that control and feeling
slightly liberated so i'll give an
example of what i mean by that
i'm always working strategically
effectively and impactfully in the best
ways i can but sometimes the place where
i put my most energy does the worst and
sometimes something that i tried on the
side like blows up and it's incredible
and that's where i've reconciled myself
down recognizing if i'm putting my best
foot forward and i'm working
strategically and effectively the things
that are going to work will work and it
may not be the things i expect and what
we're doing is or what i do sometimes
too is you're so focused on wanting one
thing to work you miss the fact that
there's like nine other things that are
happening that are amazing around you
that you could never have dreamed of and
i've seen that in my life countless
times where i wanted one thing to work
three things were working over here but
i was so like why is this not working
like why is this not working that you
missed that
so self-doubt for me is something that
i've tried to build a close relationship
with and i get it all the time i still
get it before a post before a video
before anything i mean i was just in you
know i'm working on my book right now i
just launched a podcast and before i
launched the podcast i had no idea how
well it was going to do how badly it was
going to do or anything and there was a
part of me that was like are people
going to listen to this like are people
going to care like i ask myself all
those questions still today
number one i'm glad i asked myself those
questions it means i'm human it means
that i care
it means that it's important to me
i speak at so many conferences and
everyone always asks me do you still get
nervous i go yes i get nervous because i
care the day i stop feeling nervous that
means i don't care anymore if i don't
care anymore that means i don't love
what i do anymore so for me the first
thing is i recognize that self-doubt
just shows me that i care and that
something's important to me whereas i
don't doubt myself around things that i
don't care about like if you ask me a
question right now about what's the
recipe for this amazing dish i wouldn't
know and i'd say i don't know and i'd be
okay with it because i don't care about
cooking i'm not a cook right but if it's
something that you care about you'll
you'll have self-doubt the second thing
that i do with self-doubt is i go okay
if that's the things that i'm doubting
myself for
what strategies what can i put into
place to overcome them doubt is just a
great way of making you check
what you need to work on so if my doubt
is oh my god not enough people are gonna
listen to this so i'm like okay so how
do we make it more listenable how do we
make the content better how do we make
the conversation better if my doubt is
um you know i don't feel like people are
gonna like this topic okay what themes
am i good at talking about what is you
know it's it's a great checking system
to improve what you have so don't look
at self-doubt as negative
turn it into a positive by actually
asking yourself those questions right so
build a relationship with self-doubt
because it's never going to go away
right don't avoid it don't avoid it
definitely don't avoid it it's never
going to go away so if it's never going
to go away build a happy positive
relationship with it so my positive
relationship with it is you're showing
me
what i need to focus on to feel less of
that and most of us feel self-doubt
because we're not researching we're not
building knowledge we're not building
expertise and i think that's the biggest
thing for me is when i feel self-doubt
it's because i do i'll give a perfect
example
when i was thinking about doing a
podcast and you're doing interviews
you don't just become an interviewer you
have to watch interviews you have to
absorb good interviewers you've you
can't just be an interviewee you have to
watch good interviewees and so for me
a lot of us start something and we feel
self-doubt because we've never learned
that skill or we've never observed that
skill
so my focus is if i want to be a good
interviewer i need to watch good
interviewers if you want to be a good
stage performer watch good stage
performers if you want to be a good monk
watch good monks right you don't become
something good without seeing it
so
self-doubt comes because you haven't up
skilled and the great thing today is you
can do an online course you can upscale
from here you can obscure from there you
can just listen to this podcast and
watch you guys who've done it for such a
long period of time that's a seeing
someone who's done something
consistently
that's the best way of getting good at
something and then your self-doubt will
disappear so self-doubt can only be cut
by the sword of knowledge it can only be
cut by the sword of upskilling so that's
where it starts right love is a doing
word it's active it's a verb
and if love is a verb then service is
the action and that's why love and
service
have to be so intertwined because i feel
that today when we talk about love the
definition is so skewed
when people hear the word love that's
what the problem is that's what the
problem is that's why i prefer service
to love
because service is the activation of
love
when someone loves someone they serve
that's how love works and i think that's
why when we talk about love i agree
it's just because of phonetics
definitions
breaking it down
love has become so
badly abused like the word love is so
abused and misused in our lives it
really is right you say i love you to
people you don't love people use it to
manipulate people
we just throw love around right and as
much as it should be everywhere
it's also sacred
love's also sacred and that's why you
were able to experience it because it
was experienced through a sacred
mechanism you're able to experience love
yeah and i and i've never felt it like
that before because it also was this
sense of self-love as well yeah and
that's what you felt in jerusalem too
when you went and that's what i felt and
and that's what i feel that we
experience love when it's through
service and engagement in that
atmosphere we don't just experience it
every single day i personally also
having become a i feel like i've become
even more of a seeker since being
involved
and that's opened me up to alternative
ideas alternative ways of thinking
learning from all different traditions
wherever i can and and i think that's a
really important part i think the
challenge with being a
immature seeker in my definition of it
is you find something it sounds cool and
you go that's it there's nothing else
and then a real seeker goes well that is
it but how can everything else even
enhance this and make this even greater
for me if this is where my faith is or
this is where my belief system is so i'm
someone who genuinely loves learning
from people from all different walks of
life and backgrounds because i feel
if i was presented with a deeper more
meaningful philosophy and life structure
i would adopt it
that's why because i'm open to that we
were left on the streets for 30 days to
offend for ourselves and to figure it
out just that's it you've got your
clothes that you're wearing there's no
money no food no shelter no nothing
figure it out
and
day one i'm like okay like you know
maybe it's a joke like maybe maybe
they're gonna come back at night and be
like no guys you know so i'm trying to
figure out what it is this is training
mode
and it's really interesting what what
your mind and body does so the first
thing your mind and body does when you
have nothing is you have fear
the first thing you feel is fear
and that we can all relate to in life
the first thing you feel when you all of
a sudden feel that your plan and you
have no nothing organized and you have
no structure and shelter and all of this
stuff that we now rely on you have fear
now the fact that you're there on your
own and you don't have a phone and you
can't just call someone up and you don't
know the city that you're in
your next thing is survival right fear
leads to survival mode so you're trying
to find food from everywhere you're
trying to hoard it you're trying to get
it from everywhere you're trying to keep
it you're trying to figure out like how
can i get lots of this so that i can
take care of myself and you start just
becoming crazy almost and it's funny
because those two experiences are so
similar to what you see in society today
yeah fear
breeds survival mode which breeds greed
and hoarding and wanting to have
abundance lack of abundance exactly and
so you do that in that scenario for like
remember this is a 30-day experiment
that's crazy so you do that for like the
first week
you do that for the first week where you
just want to find anywhere steel look
it's not steel trying not to steal but
like finding fruits of trees whatever
you're just trying to do whatever you
can finding anywhere to sleep and you're
offending for yourself it's all about
you the interesting thing that happens
in week two is that you recognize
that
you recognize that you really want
to
when you make a difference in someone's
life they'll help you
so by week two you start recognizing if
i help villagers if i help this old lady
if i help this old man if i serve the
people around me
then they'll give it to me anyway and we
saw people inviting us into their homes
we saw people giving us food we saw
people cooking for us just because we
were helping people wow and you start to
see community you start to see the value
of collaboration you start to see the
value of energy exchange you start to
learn
how
your heart and soul leads to other
people giving you their heart and soul
and and you experience that now the
interesting thing is that goes on for
about two weeks and you think you've
kind of mastered it right and then the
biggest challenge comes when this is
what you're meant to grow to and this is
where you go beyond
feeling good
about serving and getting an exchange
and this is not spoke about as prominent
today because i think we live in a world
where people aren't self-loved and
self-fueled enough to even consider this
and so we talk a lot about self-love
today which i highly believe in we talk
a lot about non-judgment of yourself
today which i highly believe in but this
principle was beautiful we recognized by
the final week
that actually we were far stronger
and capable than a lot of people on the
planet a lot of people in the village
sorry that were disabled
that couldn't see that had lost their
eyesight they couldn't speak they
couldn't walk they'd broken limbs
and so by the end of it we realized that
when we served others and gained we
could actually give to those people
because they didn't have because they
weren't young men like we were they
weren't able men like we were they
weren't skilled like we were
and now you can even go another you
could go another level it wasn't just
that you could take yourself you could
go another level but those three stages
of transformation show us exactly the
three stages we need the first is
getting over your greed and ego
the second one is recognizing that you
have value and when you serve others
there's a value exchange and the third
when you're feeling full and overflowing
you can then overflow to others
and so for me that 30 days like has
transformed my life ever since
because i was able to experience all of
the experiences we experienced today but
in heightened mode like i didn't know
where i was going to sleep or i was
going to eat
and and when you experience it at that
extreme
and you're able to work it out
now in with you have more perspective
you have more gratitude you have more
ability to navigate that emotion again
and you recognize that it is an emotion
so for me that was one of the most
transformative things that i've ever
done wow that's powerful yeah it just
really took me on an internal journey of
overcoming fear overcoming greed and
always recognizing that you can always
go
that one step above and recognizing that
you don't you know as soon as you think
you've figured it out
recognize that you haven't
and that there can be another level and
i think for all of us that's a great
reminder for me that when i think i have
it figured out
that's the biggest reminder of there's
still another level you've got
i think on a personal level i value deep
thought because i loved rap music so i
used to listen to a lot of rap music
growing up and so people like tupac
eminem
nars etc their lyrical abilities and
their lyrical expression was a huge part
of me growing up and i used to spend a
lot of time writing lyrics myself and
playing with words and i always
enjoyed expressing things through poetry
or spoken word and when i read these
books a lot of them felt like poetry and
spoken word there were a lot of uh not
just rhyme but there was a lot of
creative expression there so i
almost was very interested or intrigued
because of the way the philosophy was
being communicated but i wouldn't say i
was
looking for it or seeking or any of that
sort i was just like oh this is
impressive this is interesting thought
maybe i can apply it in my music or
maybe i can use it here it was less
about the search for knowledge or wisdom
it was more about oh this could be cool
to talk about here or this would be
interesting to extract from
and when
did it begin to change when did your
attitude towards theological texts or
great uh
spiritual works change from a kind of
utilitarian curiosity that it could be
magpied
into hold on a minute there's something
in here that's gonna alter me so i think
the big thing for me was the the first
time i met a monk and it's something
that you can usually you can't ask
someone like when was the first time you
met him
god i was just a slip of a girl then
back in kent picking apples on the coast
like oh so tell me what was your what
was your first birthday
so i remember i was around 18 years old
17 18 years old and i found out from a
friend that this monk had been invited
to speak at a university
and i was
pretty uninterested to go i didn't
wasn't really fascinated by it and i
actually remember saying to my friend as
long as we go out afterwards i'll turn
up to the event so if we go to a bar
dragged even
to
the feet of a monk by lust yeah
literally and so he said yeah i promise
you and he was getting into spirituality
and interested by these things so i went
along
and i was captivated who was it so this
man's name is he lives in india he's i
think you might have met him at the eco
village so he built the eco village so
you might have met him when you went
there in mumbai and then the krishna
consciousness eco village where it's
like 100 carbon footprint free they grow
their own fruit fruit and veg using
let's face it human poo yeah like and
like it's uh there's animals there
they're growing fragrant flowers it's
sort of amazing place it's sort of
beautiful isn't it you're like i suspect
you're like me thinking what systems
could we replicate in order to save the
world absolutely and that seems like one
so you met what so i met him again
so he came to he was speaking
and just just to put in context for
everyone listening this man is indian he
has a strong indian accent
he's not necessarily externally
attractive to the kind of person i'd be
attracted to at that time i was
attracted to tupac yeah exactly women
right and rags to riches stories i loved
celebrities and influencers and people
who'd made money like that's who i
looked up to people who had gone from
nothing to something
and then i'm here listening to this man
wearing robes and i'm totally captivated
i'm just like wow he's so fascinating
and the reason that he was fascinating
is because he was talking about selfless
service and he talked about how real
meaning real happiness real fulfillment
from life
comes when you're able to plant trees
under whose shade you do not plan to sit
so you want to give shelter to others
you want to provide things for others
without expecting something back from
them
and at that time that idea just
penetrated through my whole being why
why when it's directly contradictory to
experience up to that point why is this
message relevant so i think two things
one thing is i was looking for a thrill
in my teens and that's when i was
getting involved in all sorts of wrong
ideas wrong activities or wrong in the
sense of things that we wouldn't
recommend or want our children drugs sex
fighting totally yeah all of that
violence
petty theft all that kind of stuff and i
wasn't doing it because i wanted stuff i
was doing it because i wanted a thrill
in life and when i saw him and saw the
way he was living
he had made that process thrilling like
he looked happy
he looked more happy more content more
fulfilled than anyone i'd ever seen on
top of that he was extremely charismatic
and and i just thought i want to get to
know this man and then i found out that
he'd given up jobs at some of the
biggest companies in the world and he
went to iit and it studied at iit which
is the mit of india the indian institute
of technology he was like a gold
medalist at this place and he'd given
that all up to be a monk to serve
humanity
and i thought wow that's that's
unbelievable because he's given up
everything that everyone that i know is
chasing
but he's happy
and he's found meaning and he's found
that fulfillment that i feel is just
emanating from who he is so it was the
first time in my life where i'd gone
from not looking up to someone who went
from nothing to something but someone
had gone from something to nothing
and and i and that was a massive
paradigm shift moment for me and a
massive moment of just
wow there is more out there and and i
constantly say this and i say often it's
you can't be what you can't see i would
not have wanted to be a monk if i didn't
see a monk who was fulfilled and happy
and had had this power about him and up
until that point anyone that i'd seen
that was rich or successful or beautiful
or had a beautiful looking model
girlfriend or whatever it was they still
didn't emanate that happiness for me so
i saw that very early on not in the
extreme sense i didn't have celebrity
friends or anything but
from what i saw i could very clearly see
that material things
weren't making people deeply happy and
he was someone who had given that up and
seemed happy to me there's a beautiful
indian story about a musketeer with a
really powerful lesson now you may have
already heard of musk maybe because it
exists in your perfumes or your
aftershaves or deodorants as a scent
and this scent is one of the most
expensive natural products in the world
fetching three times its weight in gold
now when this deer comes across this
aroma this scent it becomes completely
captivated it searches through the
forest day and night for the source of
this scent completely intoxicated by
this incredible fragrance the deer
searches in every corner in every place
to find where it's coming from the deer
completely exhaust itself
looking for the source
with the bitter irony
and not recognizing
that the fragrance
comes from inside its own body
the fragrance mask is produced in a
gland in the deer's body the deer spends
its whole life searching for outside
what was always hidden inside
i heard this example when i lived as a
monk to describe the human condition of
life how we spend our whole lives
looking for pleasures and happiness
outside of us when actually what we're
searching for is right there inside of
us we try to find joy and happiness and
external pleasures in things in results
when actually
real happiness comes from meaning
relationships and a connection with
oneself
see we all know that we can't love
someone we don't know
so how can you love yourself when you
don't know yourself
and just as this musk dear we've
probably had similar experiences
how many times have you walked out of
your home and then felt that you've
forgotten one of those top three things
usually your keys your wallet or purse
or your phone you rush back in you look
around your own home you make a mess you
make havoc you look under every seat
every corner
and then realize that that phone that
wallet or purse or those keys were in
your back pocket in the process of
seeking happiness externally we make a
complete mess of our minds and life and
sometimes even the lives of others
not realizing that what we were truly
looking for
has always been with us today we hear a
lot about self-love and self-care
but neither of these are possible
without self-knowledge
without self-realization without
self-awareness
remember if we don't know ourselves
we can't love ourselves i remember and
this is like one of those moments i
remember being 10 years old
in the school playground
the cutest girl at school had just found
out that i fancied her like every other
guy at school liked her and i remember a
group of girls standing behind me in the
playground just taking the mick out of
me and taking the fun out of me saying
oh how can jay think that he could be
with her because he's so ugly and fat
and all the rest of it and and and i
look back at that i'm so happy it
happened because i think it's it's let
me be more compassionate let me be more
empathetic it's let me
not be egotistical it's it's it's
humbled me and made me more grateful and
realize how much hard work it is being
any different any way that we are and so
more accepting of reality so i'm not
upset about it at all it's something
that
i think helped me our identity should
start with unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves okay how do we unlearn so the
best method of unlearning is this first
and i'm going to get really strategic
and tactical because i think that people
need to know what to do rather than a
concert the first thing you do is write
down everything you currently are
chasing in your life make a lot of goals
your dreams your goals your dreams
anything that you're currently chasing
and pursuing okay write them down you
can write down three equal random five
you can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are second line ask
yourself what is the source of that
where did you get that idea did you get
that idea from
a tv show you saw did you get that idea
from your parents did you get that idea
from your mom and your dad your sister
your cousin did you get that idea
because your friend just got proposed to
on instagram did you get that idea
because your friend just got promoted
did you get that idea because
you just broke up right or did you get
the idea because you just feel it when
you do it then you feel alive just give
me a specific example that you had when
you were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing and
where it came from absolutely so my my
goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker
and when i really asked myself where did
that come from it came because in my
community small community in london the
most successful person financially was
an investment banker so i believed you
had to be an investment banker to be
successful right so when i asked myself
that question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine and then the third
thing you ask yourself is well then what
is mine what is coming from inside of me
and if you just do that three-step
process now what you're doing is you're
filtering out the noise and you're
starting to listen to your voice the
thing is you've got a voice inside of
you but it's quiet it's like it's like
jay like take note of me like lewis you
know and it's just like trying to get
through and the noise of everyone else's
opinions is so loud so this way you
filter it we always have been trained to
focus on the results so people ask what
do you want in life i'm like forget that
that's the worst question to ask someone
because when you ask what you want
that's when the ads come in and you're
like oh i want that car i want that home
i want that dress i want that body i
want whatever it is
i my question to you is what do you want
to wake up and be every day like what do
you want to wake up and do every day
what's the process that you're in love
with
so we're thinking about the result
whereas my question is forget the result
what's the process that you're in love
with doing
so start there first of all don't start
your journey of saying i want to be a
movie director because i want to you
know i want to hit the blockbuster chart
so i want to do this don't make it about
that like don't don't be like i want to
be a singer because i want to be ariana
grande right like that's not the point
that's just a result
do you love singing every day and i
realize this with a very honest question
to myself i'm really passionate about
football soccer i absolutely love the
game i grew up on it i'm still a huge
fan i missed out on it when i was a monk
i've been catching up ever since like
i'm like oh any football game i was just
in london last week and i made sure i
went i didn't couldn't see a game live
but i went and watched it at a bar in
london and i love the energy i'm so
passionate about soccer
i don't have what it takes to be a
soccer player yeah like i do not want to
wake up
i wake up at 4am to meditate when i was
a monk i wake up at 6 00 5 30 a.m now to
meditate
i do not want to wake up at 4 a.m to go
out on a reigning pitch
and play soccer like i don't want to be
in the gym for four hours a day i want
to meditate for four hours a day but i
don't want to me play soccer for four
hours a day and then be in the gym and
train i'm not envious of
any athlete in the world because it
takes a different type of mindset i
really believe that everything we say
that beautiful thought from gandhi where
he said that when what you think what
you say and what you do are in line then
you'll experience harmony and and i've
really taken that to heart and it's it's
this powerful spiritual principle and it
really means you think what you say and
what you do are aligned and so for me
any form of language any form of your
emotional vocabulary is building your
mental reality and i think people forget
that their vocabulary is defining their
life you are creating your life on a
daily basis by the words you use so for
me and i'm not saying that i feel that
way about everyone else i'm saying
that's how i feel about that word
someone may say oh when i say swear but
it makes me laugh for me it doesn't that
i would only swear when i
felt
bad i felt something negative towards
something so for me that had negative
emotions negative connotations and
negative intention attached to it so i
wanted to remove anything from my
vocabulary that i felt was negative so
even as simple as and i've done this
very recently but it's changed my life
instead of me saying i'm busy or it's
been a busy week i say i'm having a
productive week and i feel different
when i go to bed just by that simple
change i go to bed thinking yeah i've
had a really productive day today rather
than going god i had a busy day today i
don't want to wake up tomorrow i'm going
to have a busy day tomorrow and so that
simple emotional vocabulary change has
just
catapulted my mind into feeling excited
and enthusiastic all the time i was
really shy i didn't enjoy stages i
didn't enjoy speaking my parents forced
me to go to public speaking and drama
school so i spent 14 to 18 in public
speaking drama school changed my life i
did not know what i wanted to speak
about so even when i finished at 18 i
still didn't like going on stage because
i didn't have anything to talk about so
now you've got the tools but you haven't
got the passion so i developed somewhat
of an expertise in four years but i
didn't have what i was passionate about
and when i became a monk
i was like this is it this is why i went
to public speaking school because i love
talking about philosophy i love talking
about science i love talking about
culture i love talking about
life i love talking about growth etc the
mind so i got what i was passionate
about when i became a monk
so for me the process came from four
years of consistent public speaking
school like it changed my life
and and that's all thanks to my parents
for forcing me to go i had no interest
in being a public speaker or a
storyteller any of these things that was
just i lucked out
and then it was me finding what i was
passionate to speak about and then i've
spoken i've spoken for three hours a day
for the last 13 years
and i spoke to audiences of zero
all the way to audiences now of
thousands but when i first started
speaking i remember i was invited to
speak at a university where i wasn't
getting paid for i was like 20 years old
i was invited to speak to this
university no one showed up
twice so they organized two events for
me i was meant to speak about life
philosophy et cetera all the kind of
stuff i speak about now and zero people
turned up and i practiced my speech both
times to an empty room as if it was a
packed room because i was like i'm still
gonna practice and so for me having done
this for three hours a day for the last
13 years that's
now being
gratefully received online so i'm very
fortunate that it's shifted from an
offline world to an online world which
we can dive into but the point is it's
it's been my absorption and addiction
for like
for over a decade now one of the biggest
mistakes we make is that we confuse
inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if i've
never spoken on a stage i just think oh
i'm probably not good at that or if i've
never played golf i'd probably think i'm
probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method i can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days and get really
tactical every single day that's why
you're playing tennis a lot right now
yeah
take the eight days go join a course an
online course or workshop go and shadow
a friend go to a seminar or a conference
go to reading a book listen to podcasts
go and expose yourself to eight
different things in a month eight
different things eight different things
in a month and guess what in a month you
will have learned what you probably
would have learned in eight years
because most of us test one new thing a
year maybe maybe if that exactly right
like some people don't even do that but
if you do eight different things in a
month and this is how you have to see it
if you went to eight different
restaurants in a month you asked
yourself after you eat a meal like i had
that burrito or i had that taco did i
like it
right the first question you asked
yourself is did i gotta try it first you
gotta try it first you gotta go to the
restaurant yeah there's no point so
you're gonna say did i like it the
second question you ask yourself is why
did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why did i like and the third
question you have to ask yourself really
really simple is do i want to do it
again
and if you do
that's where you start uncovering is so
my point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification in the hope for money in
the hope for success we end up chasing
the wrong things and we make a mess we
end up with less than we started with
end up with more issues than we
bargained for whilst climbing that
ladder and that stairway we forget why
we started climbing in the first place
once the king of bhutan was asked by an
interviewer what the gdp of bhutan was
he was surprised and shocked
he replied by saying in bhutan we don't
just measure the gdp
we measure the gnh instead of just
measuring the gross domestic product
we measure gross national happiness in
the process of getting older we forget
the real goal of life
if you could make a little less and
spend more time doing what you love
would that make you happier
don't trade your happiness for what you
think you need
things can never make us happy because
they're temporary and limited
but experiences can last forever too
many people are working hard on things
they don't love to spend money they
don't have to buy things they don't need
to impress people they don't like
when we create our identity around what
we do a career a job an occupation we
can never be happy because we're basing
it on something external but when we
create an identity around who we are and
what we want to be and become than
anything is possible and remember
we become successful by what we get
but we become happy by what we give
don't get the two confused i start off
the chapter with this beautiful thought
from charles horton cooley and i love
telling it because it's just it's just
the best and i think it was written in
like the 1900s and he said today the
challenge is i'm not what i think i am
i'm not what you think i am i am what i
think you think i am it's crazy man and
it's like it blows my mind every time i
say it gives me the chills like i feel
it and the reason why i start with
identity is because i think that's the
root of all our challenges and the first
step to thinking like a monk is starting
at the root not starting at the symptoms
or the superficial or the surface level
but let's go to the root
if you're playing a role if you're
wearing a mask
if you're dressed in clothes that are
not yours
then you end up living a life that's not
yours and in the book i give this
example of method acting yes
yeah amazing i'm a massive movie junkie
and i love method actors so people like
heath ledger of course from the dark
knight series you've got jared leto so
jared leto when he played the joker in
this is not in the book in suicide squad
he used to send dead rats in the mail to
his co-stars he did because he was
trying to get into the mindset of how
someone that perverted would behave
and then daniel dave lewis when he was
filming for gangs of new york he's
actually wearing these coats that are
centuries old so that he can get into
character while he's off camera yeah
when he can feel it right he's not
wearing watches he's not carrying around
his mobile phone they're speaking in the
accents and he talks about how he
actually went crazy because guess what
when you fake being someone for so long
you think it's your reality
and that's what happens to all of us we
play a role at work we play a role at
home we play a role with our family we
play a role in our friends and then we
think that role is us right and we lose
ourselves and to me that is the core
reason why we're chasing things that are
not important to us the envy actually
is more of a
expression of how we feel about
ourselves rather than how we're
perceiving someone else it's actually so
much more about how comfortable we feel
with who we are how confident we feel
with who we are how much self-esteem we
have how much self-assurance we have
enemy is more a root of that than it is
of the fact that someone else is doing
well it's less about the fact that
someone out there is amazing making
waves doing something that you want to
be doing it's more about how we feel
about ourselves and it's
experienced in that way of looking at
someone else and reflecting back on us
social circles family circles someone
else has done amazingly in their exams
someone just landed a new job someone
else just got promoted and everyone's
looking at you going what are you doing
right what have you achieved where where
are you today where have you got right
what's happening with you tell us about
you
and you're thinking you know you're
going through all your head you're
trying to come up with all the things
that you've thought about all the things
that you've achieved all the things that
you've done and you're trying to bring
it up like constantly but you're
struggling you find it hard because
you're now measuring your growth
based on someone else's you're now
measuring your success based on someone
else's and that is the
biggest challenge with envy that one of
the biggest challenges it brings in our
life is that it forces us to start
measuring our sex
sorry our success in comparison to
someone else's that is the biggest
challenge with envy
when we start comparing the level of our
success with someone else's you're
already on the wrong foot i think any
sorts of
dress or any sort of
whether it be yeah dress or appearance
or any of that if it's taking you away
from who you actually are and how you
like expressing yourself then then that
kind of contradicts
being able to be authentic and being
real so i feel more authentic wearing
this than i did wearing my robes when i
was a monk literally use your weekends
and evenings to do a test on anything
the best way is go into a course test it
out try doing it once go and shadow
someone who does it someone in your life
that does it if you want to be a
podcaster come and shadow you guys for a
week right and see what that life's like
see what it actually looks like to
research to sit with a guest to find new
guests to work it out like go and shadow
someone who's already doing it and then
try and do it for a day like try and do
the schedule of someone you look up to
for a day like if you can do that for a
day and you loved it then do it for one
more day and if you loved it do it for
another day and that's gonna trickle in
so that's a much smarter way to finding
your passion rather than just sitting
there and reflecting which is cool which
is important but i'd encourage you to
just get out there right get out there
and live the life of someone who's doing
it when they started that's another
point
don't focus on what people are doing now
focus on what they were doing when they
started so a lot of people ask me
they're like jay how many videos do you
make a week i'm like i make three videos
a week plus my podcast on top of that
plus instagram and they'll say oh wow
that's too much and i was like yeah but
when i started i made one video a week
right like you don't have to start at
what i'm doing now like you you start so
that you know go back to that how boring
would it be to live in a world where
everyone was just like us imagine if
everyone in your life talked like you
thought like to walk like you
the world would be a boring place
there'd be no new cultures to explore no
new languages to learn
no new adventures to be had
if while you're writing your book if
while you're recording your podcast if
you're sitting there going i hope this
is going to be number one this better be
number one i hope i sell more i hope i
sell more copies than this person who's
launching at the same time because
that's the only way well guess what
now the quality of your output right now
has just dropped
because guess what you're now living 75
in the future and you're 25 right now
and guess what this 25 is gonna define
that future goal and result and your
happiness and you're happy whether you
get the result or not totally whereas
for me when i was writing my book and of
course i want my book to be a
bestselling book of course i want my
podcast to do well of course we don't do
anything for it to be lost like no one
does that but what i do know is that
when i'm creating when i'm producing
when i'm writing
that's all i'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent of the world's
population can multitask now the crazy
thing is when are those two percent when
two percent when people hear that they
think i'm in that oh i'm in that two
percent like everyone thinks that
they're in there but most of us are 98
yeah and the truth is there is no such
thing as multitasking what it is is fast
switching between two tasks and the
quality is just dropping because you can
actually you cannot do two things at one
time you cannot no one genuinely can do
two things at once i guess you could
maybe like pat your head and do this and
say yeah yeah
you can't do something productive at the
same time right or creative and so what
i'm saying is that when you're sitting
here going this needs to be number one
you are reducing that things ability to
be number one because it now doesn't
have your full focus right
so so that's the difference maker that
you can want to be number one there's
nothing wrong with that but you can't
keep comparing what number one is to
someone else's goal too because
everyone's got a different trajectory
like there are some people that are kind
of come in and do really well at one
thing and you're going to do really well
at another and that's why competition
has to first be in your space like don't
compete in a space that's not yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get lost
your identity exactly
i'd literally experimented with
everything with my health even as a monk
and i tried week-long fasts and i'd
pushed myself without sleep especially
about four to six hours a night and i
got to a point where i was like i need
to take care of my health i need to make
my health a priority because i was so
fascinated about mastering the mind that
i almost neglected the needs of the body
and i can definitely say that i got to
incredible places with my mind
but at the expense of sacrificing my
caretaking of my body and i felt i
wanted to go back and do both of them
together and so a lot of my friends will
say jay you always look like you've got
something exciting going on in life and
i'm like yeah i do but that's because
like nine people told me that my other
ideas sucked right and so like i've i
get more wins because i get more
failures because i'm failing so often
i'm trying so many things out so often
that don't go right and then everyone
sees the one thing that goes right and
that's how it works and that's the odds
for anyone that's not just me
anyone who's doing what they love every
day is trying a hundred different things
and most of them are not working but
because they're playing the game of
numbers
something's got to work like that's how
i live i'm just like if i try 10 things
this year one of them's got to work but
if i try one thing this year most likely
it probably won't work right and that's
the biggest challenge if we just up our
experiments like you're gonna you know
do something new for every weekend this
year the way i see it is that
competition
in and of itself is not good or bad and
and this is like the monk mindset on 99
of things that this mug is not good or
bad it can be filled with water or it
could be filled with poison yes and so
competition i'll give you an example as
monks our competition is in how much
love and respect we showed to each other
that's your comment that's what you
compete on or how long can we meditate
before no no no i can meditate longer
than you so if any monk is hit and i did
this plenty of times really if i sat
there and i thought oh yeah look at him
he's scratching his back he got out like
he moved your meditation just got
destroyed
all the value and so monks will never
ask how long you meditate they focus on
how deep you meditate and someone who
meditates deep doesn't go on about how
deep it was but but you compete for
showing respect you compete for serving
each other you compete for how well you
can collaborate and i feel like you live
this yes like i i feel like you haven't
you used
like i feel like we're always trying to
find a way where we can be better
friends to each other and support each
other
and so you're competing on that
and and that's a positive competition
that i think you can have so you can
still use and this is the beautiful
thing about the monk mindset you can use
any
thing in a positive way everyone you
love and respect and look up to
that's been their path and i think
that's what's given me so much that's
what's liberated me from it like steve
jobs is one of my biggest
role models in in certain areas of his
life
and when i've read his autobiographies
biography story by walter isaacson
it's like the guy has failed so many
times yeah all of us
like most of us have a phone that's an
iphone or an apple product in our home
or whatever it is
it's like he's not worried about all
those times that went wrong because he
obviously won big in this area of his
life so my takes just everyone you look
up to whether it's an athlete an
entrepreneur a coach a ceo whatever it
is they have messed up so many times i
just know that so when you're messing up
you're on the path like you're on the
same path right and and i yeah i
encourage people to share what they're
failing at too
because it just helps
something that happens is you have to
surround yourself by
peers in a space too who understand you
and don't see you as competition
and that's really hard and it's like a
fine line i genuinely believe that
collaboration wins always
so i my whole approach to most things
has always been hey i want to
collaborate with you whether i'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media i'm just like i just want to work
together because i think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success in numbers but
more in terms of i want to be friends
with you
and so i reach out regularly to people
that i admire in different ways
and i reach out to them and say hey i'd
love to get to know you i'd love to
learn from you i'd love to connect i'd
love to be a friend like not i'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this
and if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that i've just got a great friend
who now gets me so i try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
i feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do
are just so great because they already
get you right and
someone that i had on my podcast lately
her name's lily singh superwoman
she's become a recent friend she's been
incredibly and is incredibly successful
on social media she's using her platform
for doing amazing good in the world
and she was someone i reached out to
because i was just like hey like you've
been doing all of this for a while you
started on youtube a lot longer than i
did and i would just love to connect
from you and hear from you and she's
become an incredible friend
and we've just been sharing ideas and
learning together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time i'm trying to find people who
are not in media so i still have
friendships with the monks back in india
and i just spent january in india for a
month i was meditating again for for
roughly about 21 days
and i have them in my life because they
remind me of like the roots and they
remind me of the truths that bring me
back
so i kind of like both i love people who
totally get my space
and usually those are people i reach out
to
and then i love having my roots down so
most of my inner circle now is from
people i've reached out to
or they've become people who've been
reaching out to me for a long long time
and have been consistently reaching out
to me asking for nothing i'd say i was
quite rebellious and independent even as
a monk a lot of part of amongst life is
conforming and accepting authority and
following a path and those are all
beautiful things for people
who who like those things for me it was
a great training ground and a great
system of giving me abilities and skills
and habits that i didn't have before but
then i really felt a deep calling in my
heart to want to share this in a
specific way so i i kind of feel dragged
to do what i do now because it's so
deeply in me to want to make things
relevant non-sectarian universal and
accepting of all truths and paths it's
just
it's just there and i can't ignore it
and i got to a point in my monk life or
i just felt like i can't ignore this
desire to want to go and spread this
wisdom and insight in a way
independently in a way that i feel
will work and help people you know from
an impact point of view and so that was
a big part of it the challenge is that
we think
things
come with emotions
feelings we think things come with
feelings and emotions and guess what
they don't so if you chase money well
they might for a moment right or they
won't i don't think they even do also
it's such a false sense of feeling i
don't know maybe for a moment but it's
so short-lived that it's it's not even
worth counting almost so it's like when
you
when you think that i'm chasing money
guess what you will get money yep and
that's great money is really important
and money is a really important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life what are most people missing we're
missing a deep sense of love i think i
think the biggest need in the world as
we've heard many times before from all
the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling of false sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing what we crave
in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents what our parents did give us is
what we continue to crave or what they
didn't give us is what we continue to
crave so you'll find that most people's
love languages that they chase
are things that their parents didn't
give them so if their parents didn't
give them time they now crave everyone's
time if their parents didn't give them
gifts they'd crave gifts if their
parents didn't give them
acts of service they're craving those
acts of service so it's because of our
childhood
and if we don't learn
to process all of that experience which
most people never get the time to do and
and i empathize with that because i've
had to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns i've seen
something you were craving so i would
crave a big thing for me was i would
crave surprises and gifts because that's
your thing yeah that's my thing is your
thing they still might be yeah and and i
did your parents not do that for you no
they didn't my mom did a lot of it
that's why you're still crazy correct so
my mom would always every year on my
birthday
she'd always surprise me with the one
thing i wanted and i wasn't spoiled
growing up i didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something you know
yeah things you want as a kid right and
she would always surprise me with that
and that became so deep rooted now i'll
give you an example when i then married
my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're gonna do the same thing totally
and should not do that no because i'm
expecting my wife to be like my mom in
the sense of i expected a surprise or
show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expected to
know that so it took communication it
took time for me to explain that so
anyway i think that's where it stems
from that desire
it doesn't come from any you can say it
comes from society and education of
course it does but i think the deepest
place it comes is what your parents did
or didn't give you that's that's where
it comes from
now i've seen some stories about some
phenomenal paralympians i've seen some
phenomenal stories about human beings
who without arms and legs have achieved
extraordinary feats
and this blows my mind because i always
think like
it's some of us have challenges in
different areas but imagine being born
without legs or arms or you know like
actually not having stuff that we all
take for granted
but those are like
for some people that would be an
absolute dream to have that now through
robotics and bionic limbs they can have
that but for years they've lived without
it but still seen i've seen positivity
in them i've seen driving them i've seen
a desire in them to achieve something
phenomenal so it's amazing what's
happening out there we really have to
connect with those stories rather than
living in our small bubble and often
because we only live in our small bubble
we talk to the same people
right one of the biggest challenges with
envy is that we talk to the same people
and they talk to each other so our group
is so small that we only hear the same
stuff and we kind of start living as if
that bubble of life is real a young boy
once asked his teacher
what's the difference between i like you
and i love you the teacher beautifully
answered well it's like a flower if you
like a flower
you pluck it but if you love a flower
you water it and nurture it daily and
watch it grow there is such a thin line
between light and love and because of it
we make so many mistakes in our
relationships when we want something in
the moment we take it
and don't think any further we do
whatever we want to get that feeling of
pleasure
not realizing that we're neither
satisfied by that pleasure and nor will
that thing last when we pluck a flower
not only will that flower die
but we can't experience it for any
longer than that moment
when you water it and take care of it
daily
you can experience it forever
we've been wired towards an instant
gratification instant pleasure mindset
all of the adverts that we see whether
they're online or offline are geared to
driving us towards making instant
decisions for instant promises of
pleasure the catch is
not only does that instant pleasure not
satisfy us
the feeling doesn't last we're so used
to seeing all the strap lines and
headlines on the internet learn this
language in five minutes get the ideal
body in 10 minutes a day become a
millionaire in 12 months now all of
these sound brilliant right
the problem is they're not real they're
not true they're false promises the
reason why it works is because it
appeals to one of the most basic human
desires
situational improvement without major
resource investment
of course you can pick up a few words in
another language or shed a few pounds of
weight if that was your goal or maybe
you will make a little bit more money
but real knowledge
real
awareness real fitness
real business
all of these things take time
real relationships real connection
real purpose takes time naturally the
internet headlines focus on the short
term instead of the long term because
most of us would never click on
something if it said learn the language
in five years with dedicated daily
practice we wouldn't click on something
that said here is the one hour workout
that you need to do every single day and
we wouldn't click on the one that said
if you want to be a millionaire here are
the 10 failures that you'll go through
in year one how broke you might be by
year three and you may not even make it
by year nine the important lesson here
is if you want meaning if you want
purpose if you want fulfillment those
things take time once there was a farmer
who worked extremely hard he worked
diligently every single day to make sure
he had the healthiest crops and the
healthiest fields
as he worked he often looked towards the
opposite farm
that farm always seemed healthier more
lush and more green he would often start
to envy that farmer and feel some
jealousy inside of himself
he would sometimes say to himself maybe
they have better land maybe they get
more rain maybe it's because that farmer
has more money from his family or his
parents
sometimes he'd say to himself it's
because that farmer has better tools or
better tractors to plow the land often
he'd think it's because he's got more
help from his children than i do every
day
every week
every month
every year this farmer was feeling more
and more envious seeing the lush green
healthy abundant land on the other side
he'd constantly wonder and be trying to
figure out why it was
that that farmer had the greener land
till one day he realized he couldn't
stand it anymore and he was going to go
and find out he made a route with a plan
to get to the other farm he went through
the woods over the hills through thorns
through bushes to all of these
challenges to get to that side to get to
that farm and then
he finally made it
but when he got there
he was completely shocked
completely confused he thought to
himself maybe i'm lost he felt like he
was standing
on his ground again he felt like he'd
gone around in a circle and ended up in
exactly the same place
he thought this because when he looked
across again to the other farm
it looked lush green and healthy
and where he was standing
seemed average and normal but when he
looked back over to the other side
he saw his children playing on the farm
he had made it to the other side
and that day he learned an extremely
important lesson
he realized after making it to the farm
that he envied that the grass always
seems greener on the other side
but then he went one step further he
realized that the grass is not just
green on the other side
it's greener where you water it
and whoever looks for greener grass on
the other side
will never be able to recognize
notice
or appreciate
the grass that was beneath their feet
the whole
entire
time
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there